[Music]
i'll handle this
i've played this scene a million times
on broadcast oh don't say that word
how can i help you
it's money time baby
payday is here and the check is in the
mail as in the deceased murdered male at
the arconia tim cono that's right i said
murdered okay i heard murder but what
the [ __ ] else with the rest of that well
it's uh police talk isn't it no
we
are part of a concern
that has reason to believe tim cono was
murdered by the demas family
deadly people delis but also crime based
on the evidence we found on tim's fault
uh-huh how did you get said phone
oh you should
maybe
whoever did that
still has some lingering questions about
tim's death and is up against enormous
obstacles and was hoping you could help
them by releasing a podcast episode with
all your evidence so it was you
if we make that episode you don't want
to be sitting ducks i got you
i'm low-key running a tax report and
fingerprint scan off the laptop someone
typed who knows goodbye on the rest is
on you thank you so much and i am so so
sorry about the things that charles and
mabel said about you in episode one and
two
sum of three okay so
let's just make sure
we keep this tight okay especially if
you're accusing the deli king all right
so
get the who the how the why and the why
now get the what and the what see why
would you say what i never said what
there's no what it's the who
the how the why and the why now all
right make the case and make sure it's
super [ __ ] tight and we need to make
it by morning
the who
the who not the what the what no no the
why the why
[Music]
you